[تصفيق]
حمزه يوسف اول زعيم اسكتلنديا مسلم بعد
انتخابه زعيما للحزب الوطني لاسكتلندي
تمهيدا لخلافه نيكولا المستقيله كوزير
الاول
حمزه يوسف ابن ابوين هجره من باكستان الى
غلاسكو في الستينات القرن الماضي ووصوله
الى اعلى منصب سياسي في اسكتلندا لم يكن
صدفه نظرا لتجاربه السياسيه في عده مناصب
وزاريه ما سيضع في تعامل مباشر مع رئيس
وزراء بريطانيا
لمواجهه التحديات البلاد
لا اعتقد انه سيكون هناك اي توتر ملحوظ
بين القائدين على الرغم من انه بالطبع وضع
رائع بالنظر الى تاريخ الامبراطوريه
البريطانيه وهو بالتاكيد شيء يجب الاحتفال
به وشيء مثير للاهتمام وان كان هناك ما
سيقرب القائدين من بعضهما البعض فقد تكون
الخلفيه العرقيه والتجارب المتشابهه في
حياتهما خلال نش اتهما في المملكه المتحده
تعهدات حمزه يوسف بما فيها تحقيق ما فشلت
فيه سلفه بعقد استفتاء لاستقلال اسكتلندا
عن المملكه المتحده والانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيشكل النقطه الخلافيه الكبرى مع
الحكومه في لندن القائدان السوناك وحمزه
في مسار مواجهه شرسه بشان استقلال
اسكتلندا وموقف الحكومه البريطانيه ثابت
لحمايه دول الاتحاد البريطاني
افهم تماما السياق التاريخيه امامنا
واعتقد انه لا توجد اي طبقات اخرى من
الصراع ليست موجوده بالفعل فيما يتعلق
بالقوميه لسكتلنديه فانه يجب الاحتفال
بالتنوع العرقي والتوتر مع حكومه المملكه
المتحده مستمر منذ عقود ولا اعتقد ان هذا
سيكون مختلفا في المستقبل
اقليه عرقيه الان اصبحت تدير شؤون
الاغلبيه من البيض في اسكتلندا وباقي
الاراضي البريطانيه
الزعيم الاسكتلندي حمزه يوسف ورئيس
الوزراء البريطاني من ابناء المهاجرين
قدموا من مستعمرات الامبراطوريه
البريطانيه السابقه وصولهما الى اعلى
المناصب السياسيه يعكس نجاح نموذج
الاندماج في بلد كان يحكم ارض اجدادهما
مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن